hello mr brown thank you for joining us
on the programme this morning what are
you hoping for from this emergency
summit good morning
well we have a plan and we get the
vaccines out to those people who need
them so only two percent of africa
vaccinated only two percent of
low-income countries it's in our
interest in britain that they are
vaccinated because the disease will
spread in africa it will mutate and
there'll be new variants it will come
back to haunt even the fully vaccinated
in britain unless we take action so
we've been stopped by on vaccines we've
got a mountain of vaccines in america
and in europe
they're not going to be used even when
we do the boosters and the 12 to 15 year
olds there are still millions of
vaccines left over and we've got to get
them to the rest of the world otherwise
they're going to pass the use by date
and expire and be of no use to anybody
and all of us hate waste
so i don't understand why it's not as
easy as
opening up the belly of a british
airways jet putting them on board and
taking them down to joburg
well you've done charity work in africa
and you know that there's a desperate
need to get the vaccines into africa as
quickly as possible and that's what
should be being done and so in june they
had a plan that they would give does
share as they called it when they had
excess vaccines they'd pass them over
but it hasn't really happened enough and
yet there's all these vaccines lying in
warehouses or on contract for delivery
to britain america and europe and yet we
don't need them so we've got to get them
out as quickly as possible wednesday's
summit should agree a plan and it's in
everybody's interest our interest
to protect ourselves as well as to help
people in other countries do you have a
plan do you know how we should do it
yep my plan is that uh this month we
could transfer 300 million vaccines
that's from america and europe by next
month there could be 500 million and by
december a billion and so we need to get
all the resources at our disposal to
airlift them to get them out to the
countries that need them get the
vaccinations happening and provide some
support as you know okay from your
visits to africa
we need to give help to administer the
vaccines as well but that's something
we've also put in train and i've been
working with the world health
organization and other organizations to
make that happen as quickly as possible
do we have enough people because that
was going to be my next point you know
we're struggling as far as the nhs is
concerned here we haven't got any people
that we can send to put these jabs in
people's arms so what do we do we get
the vaccines there they're all there on
the runway then what do we do with them
well there's hundreds of thousands of
health workers in the low-income
countries and across africa they've not
even been vaccinated yet you know
to vaccinate all the health workers is a
huge task so that's going to happen
quickly because they're risking their
lives to save lives then we get to the
vulnerable elderly and then we get to
the rest of the population so that
africa and low-income countries can also
go back to work they're suffering
because
massive unemployment as well as massive
poverty as a result of this
i fear that unless we take this action
then africa could become the center for
covert and if in future you have new
variants and mutations coming out of
africa then it really will hurt the rest
of the world so it's in africa's
interests it's in our interest yes you
can devise a plan very quickly and
wednesday's summit they shouldn't go
around the table saying
congratulating themselves and what
they're doing they should go around the
table and say let's get a plan and let's
get all these surplus vaccines out there
and get them used because as i say what
i hate most of all about this is waste
because we've got genius of scientists
we've got the manufacturers in
delivering one and a half billion
vaccines a month and then they're lying
in warehouses
and not being used that's not good
enough and we in britain and people in
america and europe have got to get their
vaccines out to people who need them as
you say and and has often been quoted as
saying and nobody's safe unless
everybody's safe one wonders why all of
these vaccines are going to waste we
seem to have stalled here in the united
kingdom um in making sure that people
are double vaccinated i was looking at
the figures this morning 65 less than
two-thirds of the british public have
been fully vaccinated we used to lead
europe and now we're something like 7th
8th portugal spain lots of other
european countries ahead of us what's
happened
well in america and in europe as well as
in britain there is resistance among
some people to vaccinate and i want to
appeal to everybody who's not been
vaccinated
to get vaccinated and that helps them it
helps their families it helps protect
our communities so there is some
resistance and we've got to deal with
that but even if we set aside enough
vaccines for all who need them
and haven't asked for them yet and do
the boosters and do 3 million 12 to 15
year olds and get them vaccinated twice
which is 6 million vaccine vaccinations
we still have
millions of vaccines left over and by
christmas that will be 100 million if we
don't airlift them to africa and
elsewhere it could be 200 million
because of the delays in getting them to
people
and that is an excess above all the
other vaccinations that we still want to
see happen in the united kingdom
what do you think of these anti-vaxxers
with their bull horns who uh wander
around um shopping centers on a saturday
intimidating people and saying that it's
a government ploy to try and tag us
all well look i admire those people who
are not in politics and not really in
public life in the political sphere
who've gone out and said as individuals
like gareth southgate get vaccinated
and i think we need role models to
appeal to
young people and to the rest of the
community not to listen to these
anti-vexes because already we have
proved that a hundred thousand lives
have been saved in britain as a result
of vaccination
and if you think ahead to the next year
the estimate is that a million deaths
will happen across the world unless we
get vaccinations to people and that's a
huge figure of wasted lives as a result
of having wasted vaccines and so we
really have to act to persuade people to
get the vaccination but also to use the
vaccines we've got
sarah gilbert who was one of the
inventors of the astrozenica vaccine she
has been appealing to people to get the
vaccination and to get the vaccines out
to the rest of the world so people that
everybody can respect for their genius
and for their scientific achievement and
people in the world of sport and so on
are appealing to people to get
vaccinations i make that appeal today as
well
let me ask you um as a former prime
minister well i've got you've seen this
big argument that's developing between
us and the french at the moment because
um they had done a deal with the
australians to have um submarines
diesel-powered submarines and we've gone
behind their backs the french would say
and and done a deal uh with the
americans to to provide them with
nuclear submarines would you have done
it in that way um if you'd still been
prime minister
well i think we could have done it
better uh just as we could have done the
afghanistan exit a lot better and i
think there are lessons to learn and i
hope when boris johnson meets president
biden they'll discuss how the whole of
the west can work more closely together
but i think france also has an issue
here they want to if you like to have
strategic autonomy in europe and so they
will build this up as an argument
against working just with nato they want
a sort of french led european defense uh
capacity so i i think france has its own
motives for building this up but i think
we've got to learn to work better
together there is a standoff with china
at the moment if the west cannot unite
and say what it wants to see done then i
don't think we're going to be in a very
strong position to influence world
events in america and i think boris
johnson should say this to joe biden
tomorrow america used to act
unilaterally because it was a unipolar
age and they had complete hegemony now
we're in a multi-polar age and they've
got to work with other countries and
britain and america's partnership is
really important to that so i hope on
practical uh decisions that are made
tomorrow when boris johnson meets
president biden we can see the alliances
working far better than they did in
afghanistan
but how concerned are you that you know
our closest defense ally in the form of
the french i've withdrawn their
ambassadors from australia and also from
the us and have pulled out of defense
talks with the united kingdom later on
in the week now you know they're french
they might be a little bit sulky about
it but they are our closest defense
allies we do need to work with them
while uh organizations like the
americans are keeping an eye on what's
happening in the far east
yeah well as i've said i think this is
more to do with french domestic politics
i think president macron is asserting
the importance that he attaches to
french
involvement in the defense of the west
and the defense of the world and i think
this will blow over pretty pretty
quickly in my view but what we've got to
watch is that there's a split over time
between the french wanting to take
europe one way
and the americans britain and nato
wanting to go another way i think that's
something we must leave it there mr
brown i'm so sorry we're out of time
thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning